in this video i really just want to
introduce you to some terminology for
some basic angle types and the
terminology i want to introduce you to
are acute angles
acute angles
right angles
right angles and obtuse
and obtuse angles and i think when we
just go through these it'll be pretty
self-explanatory
an acute angle is an angle
well let me just draw them first then
you might you might it might start to
make sense so an acute angle will look
something like that i draw two arrays
that are coming from a common point i
could also so the acute angle will be
this angle right over here i could also
draw an acute angle maybe
an angle that's formed from the
intersection of two lines
this angle will be acute and so will
this angle they're both acute angles and
we're going to see is acute angles are
ones that are without since i haven't
defined right angles yet they're
narrower and we're going to see that
they're smaller than right angles right
angles are when the rays or the lines
are
going
i guess in the comp it
i don't want to use the word right in my
definition but they're kind of if one is
going horizontal the other one will be
going vertical so let me draw it with
rays first so the right angle this one's
going from the left to the right then
the other ray is going from the bottom
to the top this angle right over here is
a right angle and i could label it like
that as a traditional angle but the
general the general convention for
labeling right angles is to put a little
kind of a half of a box right over there
and that tells me that that is a
right
that means that that is a right angle or
that if this is going left to right this
is going perfectly top to bottom that
there that this is in no way kind of
it's completely i guess the best way to
think about it and why it's called right
is that this ray is completely upright
compared to this ray over here and let
me draw it with some lines so if i have
one line like this
and then i have another line like that
a right angle
over here actually all of these would
have to be right angles it would mean
that this line is completely if this was
the ground this line is completely
upright relative to this line over here
so either of these that's what a right
angle means and now that we've defined
right angle i can give you another
definition for an acute angle an acute
angle has a measure or smaller than a
right angle when you learn about
radians and degrees which are different
ways to measure angles you'll see that a
right angle can be measured as 90
degrees
this over here is less than 90 degrees
so this is less than
90 degrees and one way to conceptualize
is that this angle is its opening is
smaller it's more narrow it's it's a
it's a the the lines are you would have
to rotate one line less to get to the
other line than you would over here here
you'd have to move it all the way over
there here you'd only have to move it a
little bit so an acute angle is less
than a right angle and so you might
imagine already what an obtuse angle is
it is greater than a right angle so let
me draw a couple of examples of obtuse
angles so an obtuse angle might look
like
an obtuse angle might look like let me
make it a little bit clearer
might look like that
if this was a right angle this this line
over here would be would look something
like that it would be completely upright
relative to this if this were the ground
but we don't see we don't see that this
orange ray over here is actually opened
out wider it's opened up wider so it is
obtuse
it is obtuse and this kind of comes from
the actual everyday meaning acute means
very sharp or very sensitive obtuse
means not very sharp or not very
sensitive so you could imagine this
looks like a sharp point or it's it's
not opening up much so maybe it's more
sensitive to you know relative to other
things or i don't know i'm just trying
to make connections this is less
sensitive it's all big and open it won't
be able to notice things that are small
because i don't know
maybe maybe that's not an appropriate
analogy but one way to think about it
it's kind of opened up wider or it's
bigger than a right angle it's larger
than 90 degrees larger than a 90 degrees
if you measure it you would have to
rotate this rate more to get to that to
to get to this other ray than you would
if they were right angles and definitely
a lot more than if they were acute
angles if i were to draw this with lines
if i were to draw this with lines which
of the angles are obtuse and which are
acute
well the way i've drawn them right over
here these two over here are acute
are acute and then these over here are
going to be obtuse this one and this one
these are both
these are both obtuse angles and i
actually drew it up here as well
this one and this one are going to be
obtuse so very simple idea if if one if
one line or one ray relative to the
other one is straight up and down versus
the left and right or it's completely
upright then we're talking about a right
angle if they are closer to each other
if you have to rotate them less you're
talking about an acute angle if you have
to rotate them more you're talking about
an obtuse angle and i think when you
just look at them visually it's pretty
easy to pick out